SPEAKER 1: Google Summer of
Code is a mentorship program
from Google.
SPEAKER 2: Google Summer of Code
matches mentors and programmers
in university to work on
important open source projects
that everyone benefits from.
SPEAKER 3: This past summer,
over 175 organizations
from around the globe--
SPEAKER 4: --welcomed
1,200 new developers--
SPEAKER 5: --into
the communities
and the world of open source.
SPEAKER 7: Does your
open source organization
have a project that could--
SPEAKER 8: --use a boost
from some fresh ideas?
SPEAKER 9: Want some contagious
enthusiasm and breathless
innovation?
SPEAKER 10: You should
apply to participate
in the Google Summer of Code.
SPEAKER 11: Your project
will get worldwide exposure.
SPEAKER 12: You'll make
new, lasting friendships.
SPEAKER 13: And you'll
have a great time.
SPEAKER 14: This is a
great way for you give back
to the open source community--
SPEAKER 15: --by introducing a
new generation to open source.
SPEAKER 16: The rewards spread
beyond our own projects.
SPEAKER 17: Because bringing
new programmers into open source
benefits everybody.
SPEAKER 18: Visit g.go/gsoc to
learn more and get involved.